and 35 years old and that just three
months ago I wrote the first check in my
life it was something for another at my
my son's public school and there was a
sports group or something I needed to
pay for and I tried the debit cards and
credit cards and square and PayPal and
all the normal things you would use when
you want to give some people money the
one thing I didn't try was wire transfer
because last time I tried that in the
u.s. bank I had to walk over to the
office fill out two pages on paper and
spend like an hour so I ended up putting
pen and paper I wrote the check then a
few weeks ago I went to San Francisco I
parked on the street get out of my car
parked by mobile as any other normal
person would do and as I later found out
two or three minutes later I had gotten
a ticket for illegal parking no big deal
went to the San Francisco municipal
transportation agency website where you
can pay online for your tickets guess
that you could also argue with them
haha print out two pages of paper sign
them on paper get an envelope from
summer a stamp if you remember those
things and send off some this entire
stack of paper to kick off a two-week
dialogue by snail mail just to prove
that you did nothing wrong
this story's from the 19th century would
actually be quite amusing if there
weren't that sad like it's an ideal
opportunity I could pull many jokes
about the horses and curries that are on
my banks logo in this country but but
just just what makes them miserable for
me is that if you start thinking deeper
about the impact they have the miserable
waste a crate for the society that's one
secondly the context what's around us
that makes it totally and I knew like in
my limited and you know unimaginable how
these things could happen today and
firstly I'd like to share that that
there actually could be a future that
should be here now that could look much
better so let's start with a waste first
let's say just for sake of exercise
let's say that you're spending ten
minutes a week doing things that you
don't want to do but sort of have to the
unnecessary bureaucratic burden in a
year for you that easily builds up to an
entire working day so you're spending
one day a year but it's not just to you
there are 38 million people living in
the state of California so if you do the
multiplications you're looking at
hundred thousand human lives be spent
instead of working just doing this stuff
in a year in the state of California
alone and I can understand that this
formula maybe is a bit abstract so let's
translate it to something more
understandable it's 1,500 human lives
wasted and if you want to thank us just
add a zero fifteen thousand human lives
so it's like it's just unimaginable
secondly we're in Silicon Valley
we're in heart of the place where all
this beautiful consumer internet
solutions come out the from if you're
using anything on the internet that
allows you to search for things or share
pictures of watch movies or listen to
music or find the data or buy something
most of these applications come from
this part of the world why is that that
if the front page of Facebook loads two
seconds slower you become anxious but if
you're spending two hours more in the
line in DMV you think it's normal
there is no way to argue that that would
be for lack of the right technology is a
lack of talent or lack of experience
building great user interfaces for these
things to be so broken things that you
have to do shouldn't be as any harder
than the things you actually want to do
so how many of you actually know I come
from Estonia how many of you actually
know where Stone Age
as this is Stanford and the map is
invisible on screen this is a really
good score and and if if I had to ensure
probably the stories that you might have
heard if it's your first time to hear
about this Tonya would be that that
little unfortunate incident we had with
a certain community superpower who
occupied us for fifty years or the fact
that it even this time of year it can
get quite cold and dark and snowy so far
up north but there was something else
about this Tonya that I would like to
share today the the there is a think
tank called Freedom House in Washington
DC that publishes the annual report on
freedom of the net the United States of
America usually does quite well on that
chart and and this last year you guys
were number two because Estonia of
course held the first spot we have 1
million people online in this country
which doesn't sound like a lot but you
can put it to put it in perspective we
have one point twenty nine million
people in the country overall so for a
while we've had hundred percent our
government agencies and schools and most
of our businesses online and and that's
pretty cool but that is not something
that's unusual because the numbers are
quite similar in the US I think the 80
percent penetration is there so it what
it's more important is what we actually
do when we run like 99 percent the bank
transactions in Estonia happen digitally
this means that you can joke about that
there is one percent of people who are
so rich in time that they can actually
go to a bank they can afford that waste
ninety four percent of tax declarations
are submitted online and mind you this
is not like you go on a web page and
start filling out the form about your
life last year this means that all this
data flows flows throughout the year
fluidly and digitally so your taxes
submissions process is next next next
submit and if there is a thing to get
back it's on your bank account two days
later we Estonia signed the digital
signature law already back in 2001 which
means that by today 92% of Estonians
carry either a physical chip card or a
software certificate on the mobile phone
that allows them to sign
anything digitally or prove to any
website that this is how they that they
are who they actually claim to be and
you can imagine that when you have that
you because infrastructure that opens up
very interesting doors for example in
2005 already we were the first nation in
the world to hold nationwide elections
over the Internet and by 2011 over 1/4
all parliamentary votes came from that
but what is more important is that this
is not just a government thing any
person can transact with any other
person or company or the government if
they wish in a secure and provable way
I'm sharing these stories about dystonia
today just for a very simple reason
that's where I come from and that's what
I know if there are any people in the
audience who come from Singapore or
Finland or the Netherlands or many other
small places in the world you would have
similar stories so the point here is not
about to brag or to host the competition
of whose countries the coolest my
message here is that if you look at the
computing power that each and every one
of you occurring in the pocket today and
the fact that you always online there's
just no reason no excuse for the things
you have to do to be so much harder than
the things you want to do with these
devices and I would especially claim
that especially for Silicon Valley and
especially for California there is a
future that should be here now today and
for if for no other reason for the fact
that it has already arrived to so many
other places that have similar or even
lesser technological advancement and
talent around so what I would urge you
to do is that when you leave this campus
and go back to businesses or nonprofits
or the government work or whatever you
choose to do you are just being a
citizen that don't stop demanding for
these things to be better don't settle
for the defaults don't like like define
that future and help to deliver that
imagine a world where there is the DMV
lines the retail experience is designed
by Apple what would that word look like
and if you lack any of that sort of
inspiration remember that there are
these some small countries in the world
that would be happy to share thank you